Wir laufen durch den Trail, oder?
- Ja.
Die Redwoods
an der Küste Kaliforniens.
Sandra und Roli
sind auf Amerikareise.
Doch es sind keine normalen Ferien.
Vor einigen Jahren erfuhr Sandra,
dass sie
das Kind eines Samenspenders ist.
Seit sie davon weiss,
sucht Sandra ihre Wurzeln
und kommt nicht mehr zur Ruhe.
Das ist ein richtig guter Baum!
Ein Richtiger.
Ein verwurzelter, starker Baum.
Wie lässt sich
der biologische Vater finden?
Woher stammt
die andere Hälfte ihrer Gene?
Solche Fragen werden zum alles
beherrschenden Thema für Sandra.
Eine Antwort hat sie endlich
in Kalifornien gefunden.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Sandra ist in der Nähe
von Winterthur aufgewachsen.
Ich bin schon früh als Kind mit
meinem Äusseren konfrontiert worden.
Es hat immer geheissen:
"Wem von der Familie ähnelst du?"
"Du siehst so ganz anders aus
als deine Verwandten."
So gesehen haben Sie das Äussere
auch zum Beruf gemacht?
Ja, ich mag es,
Menschen zu verschönern.
Und, ähm ...
Ich mache ihnen damit
auch eine Freude.
Ich finde es sehr schön, wenn
die Kunden glücklich hinausgehen.
Sandras eigenes Lebensglück
bekam mit Anfang 30 jäh einen Riss,
als ihr das Familiengeheimnis
von einer Eingeweihten
unbedacht verraten wurde.
Mit 30 habe ich dann erfahren,
dass mein Vater
nicht mein biologischer Vater ist.
Das hat ein ziemliches Erdbeben
innerhalb der Familie gegeben.
Und bei Ihnen selbst?
Bei mir selbst gab es
einen ersten Blick in den Spiegel.
In meine Augen.
Ich habe mich wirklich gefragt,
wo die andere Hälfte ist,
wo meine anderen 50 % sind.
In diesem Moment habe ich wirklich
gedacht, das herausfinden zu müssen.
Ich musste herausfinden,
wer mein biologischer Vater ist.
Ich war nicht nur auf der Suche nach
ihm, sondern auch nach mir selbst.
Als eines der ersten Kinder
in der Schweiz
wurde Sandra anfangs der 70er-Jahre
bei einer medizinisch durchgeführten
Samenspende gezeugt.
Für ihre Mutter
war das kein einfacher Schritt.
Ich bin nach Zürich
zum Frauenarzt gegangen.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass ich
keine Kinder bekommen könne.
Und dann hatte er einen Spender.
Ich bin dort hingegangen
und die haben das so gemacht.
Eigentlich war Sandras Vater
wegen einer Mumpserkrankung
im Teenager-Alter unfruchtbar.
Auch er stimmte
dem geheim gehaltenen Eingriff zu.
Das hatten wir so beschlossen.
Ich habe das nicht
von mir aus gemacht.
Das ist besprochen worden.
Er mochte Kinder und sagte Ja.
Es war für ihn nachher
auch kein Thema mehr? - Nein.
Er hat sie behandelt wie
seine eigenen Kinder. Fertig.
Zwei Töchter wurden mittels
verschiedener Samenspender gezeugt.
Die Ärzte beschworen die Eltern,
dies den Kindern niemals zu erzählen.
Ich weiss gar nicht mehr,
warum sie es nachher erfahren haben.
Sie sind draussen gesessen und
haben geweint, zumindest Sandra.
Und dann hat sie es gesagt.
Ja.
Sie hat sich auch selbst
auf die Suche gemacht.
Ich weiss nicht, wer er es ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Für Mutter und Schwester
war das Ganze kein grosses Thema.
Sandra hingegen
konnte keine Nähe mehr
zu ihrem sozialen Vater empfinden.
Er starb kurze Zeit später.
Seitdem verfolgt Sandra
eine andere Spur.
Das ist unsere Familienwunschbox.
Da darf jeder einen Wunsch
oder Wünsche aufschreiben
und die Zettel
danach in die Box legen.
Der wichtigste Wunsch war,
dass ich meinen biologischen Vater
finden werde.
Diesen Wunsch habe ich,
seit ich 30 bin.
Und ich bin jetzt schon
seit 14 Jahren auf der Suche.
Eines Morgens habe ich den
Frauenarzt meiner Mutter angerufen.
Ich habe ihm gesagt, wer ich bin
und wie ich entstanden bin.
Ich habe ihn sehr darum gebeten,
mir zu helfen.
Und ...
... auch um meinen Seelenfrieden
finden zu können.
Er hat mir dann einfach
drei Anhaltspunkte gegeben:
Er heisse Dan, er sei Amerikaner
und er sei einer seiner
Medizinstudenten gewesen.
Mehr hat er mir nicht mehr verraten.
Ich habe ihn wahnsinnig darum gebe-
ten, mir den ganzen Namen zu nennen.
Nur mit einem Vornamen
kommt man nicht weit,
auch im Internet nicht.
Und auch mit Recherchieren
ist man chancenlos.
Ich habe sicher 2-3 Std.
auf ihn eingeredet
und ihn einfach so gebeten,
dass er es mir sagen soll
und dass es für mich wahnsinnig
wichtig ist, dass ich das weiss.
Es geht ja nun wirklich nicht
um irgendwelche finanziellen Dinge.
Es geht auch um keine Belästigung.
Es geht einfach darum, dass man
wissen will, woher man kommt
und seine Wurzeln kennt.
Aber er ist stur geblieben,
er hat nichts gesagt.
Auch Sandra bleibt stur.
Jetzt - nach vielen Jahren
vergeblichen Suchens -
fliegt sie mit ihrem Partner Roland
nach Amerika.
Dort hofft sie, endlich
ihren Seelenfrieden zu finden.
Mittlerweile
hat auch die Wissenschaft
einen Sprung nach vorne gemacht.
Gerade in Amerika sind DNA-Analysen
zur Klärung der Herkunft
sehr populär geworden.
Hilft Sandra das Vergleichen
ihres Erbgutes weiter?
Ich bin auf zwei amerikanischen
Datenbanken registriert.
Dort hatte ich
keine grossen Treffer.
Dann habe ich auf Facebook
nach DNA gesucht.
Ich habe das Wort eingegeben.
Und dann ist auf einmal
"DNA Detectives" erschienen.
Da sind
sehr viele Amerikaner registriert,
die eigentlich
ihre Vorfahren suchen,
oder Mutter, Vater oder Geschwister.
Dort habe ich
einen Aufruf gestartet.
Dann hat sich jemand gemeldet.
Es ist ein Professor aus Oregon.
Er befasst sich intensiv
mit der DNA.
Er kann auch, zu meinem Glück,
sehr gut Deutsch.
Wir haben recht schnell angefangen,
im Messenger, also privat,
einander zu schreiben.
Er hat immer wieder gesagt:
"Sandra, wir finden deinen Vater."
"Ich kann dir helfen."
* Sanfter Popsong: "Lorraine's Song"
von Theresa Angerson *
Mit dieser Hoffnung im Gepäck fliegen
Sandra und Roli nach San Francisco.
# Yesterday I had a dream.
Irrsinnig! - Man kann
bis nach vorne laufen. - Super.
Megaschön.
Wir fahren über die Golden Gate
Brücke, Richtung Norden.
Nach Santa Rosa.
- Santa Rosa, ja.
Sandra und Roli
machen sich auf den Weg,
um jenen Professor aus Oregon
zu treffen,
der ihr Rätsel
schliesslich gelöst hat.
Im nördlichen Kalifornien legt man
jedoch gerne auch mal eine Pause ein.
Mein Gott, ja.
Da hat es auch einen mit dem Baby.
* Sandra lacht. *
So herzig.
Der lässt sich in den Wellen
richtig treiben.
Das sieht so süss aus.
Im abgelegenen Motel
erinnert sich Sandra noch einmal
an die jahrelange Not
mit ihrem Halbwissen.
Nachdem sie
beim Gynäkologen ihrer Mutter
mehrmals auf Granit gebissen hat,
beginnt sie mithilfe ihres Partners
selbst zu recherchieren.
Jeder Medizinstudent, der an der Uni
studiert, muss sich einschreiben.
Und dann ...
In der Zentralbibliothek Zürich
haben wir Seite für Seite
von diesen Büchern durchgewälzt
und alle Namen,
die mit Dan angefangen haben und
amerikanische Staatsbürger waren,
herausgeschrieben.
Es hat nicht viele Amerikaner gege-
ben, die in der Schweiz studierten.
Dann bin ich auf den Namen Dan ...
gestossen und habe gedacht: "Wow!"
"Ich habe ihn gefunden."
Es stimmte alles.
- Es stimmte alles.
Deshalb kontaktiert Sandra
den potenziellen Samenspender,
der heute als Arzt
in San Francisco lebt.
Er allerdings
streitet die Vaterschaft ab.
Ich habe das einfach nicht geglaubt.
Ich habe es nicht geglaubt,
weil so viel zusammenpasste.
Wir haben ihn sogar angerufen.
- Wir hatten ihn am Telefon.
Er hat immer gesagt,
dass er es nicht sei.
Er hat aber auch gesagt,
dass er den Gynäkologen kennen würde
und in der Schweiz gewesen sei,
genau zu jener Zeit.
Und studiert hat.
- Und studiert hat.
Es hat alles, wirklich alles
gepasst, aber er sagte,
er hätte nicht gespendet.
Roli hat mir den Hörer
in die Hände gegeben.
Und dann hat er wirklich
auf Deutsch zu mir gesagt:
"Ich bin nicht dein Vater."
Dann musste ich natürlich
heftig weinen.
Trotzdem habe ich es
nicht ganz geglaubt.
All die anderen Sachen
haben einfach übereingestimmt
und es konnte nicht sein,
dass es noch einen Dan gibt,
auf den alles zutrifft.
Das war unmöglich.
Und dann habe ich auf Facebook
eine Tochter von diesem Dan gesehen.
Und dann habe ich ihr Bild gesehen.
Ich habe gedacht: "Wow,
die spielt Theater, genau wie ich,
und sie hat die gleichen Augen."
Es musste es einfach sein.
Es musste dieser Treffer sein.
Via Facebook habe ich
Kontakt zu ihr aufgenommen,
Was ich geschrieben habe ...
Ich habe dieser Tochter geschrieben,
ob sie einen DNA-Test machen würde.
Aber das wollte sie nicht.
Ja.
Alles kommt wieder hoch.
- Klar, logisch.
Wer lügt hier, wer sagt die Wahrheit?
Sandras Gewissheit, dass es
der Arzt aus San Francisco sein muss,
kommt erst ins Wanken, als Gregory
Anderson mit ihr Kontakt aufnimmt.
Er hatte sich auf ihren
Facebook-Aufruf gemeldet und gesagt,
es gäbe noch
viele Recherche-Möglichkeiten.
Er hat gesagt, er kenne sich
sehr, sehr gut aus mit der DNA
und sei einer der wenigsten,
die so viel davon verstehen würden.
Ich müsste noch einmal einen grossen
DNA-Test machen, von den USA.
Den grössten,
den es in den USA eigentlich gibt.
Ich musste dann
einen dritten DNA-Test machen.
Allein in den USA
haben in den letzten Jahren
über 10 Mio. Menschen
solche DNA-Tests gemacht.
Da kommen gewaltige Datenmengen
zusammen, und Experten können daraus
die erstaunlichsten Informationen
herauslesen.
Sandras Hoffnung wächst wieder.
Ich habe ihm geschrieben,
dass er mein Engel sei,
also mein Computerengel.
* Traurige Klaviertöne *
In Crescent City,
dem nördlichsten Punkt Kaliforniens,
treffen sich die beiden
zum ersten Mal persönlich.
Hi!
* Lachen *
Hallo! Hallo!
- Hallo.
Auch der Biochemiker freut sich,
mal wieder mit Schweizern
in Kontakt zu kommen.
Als junger Mann hat er
einige Jahre in Zürich gewohnt -
und das Studentenleben genossen.
Mein Deutsch
habe ich in der Schweiz gelernt.
Auch ein paar Brocken
auf Schweizerdeutsch:
(Schweizerdeutsch)
Geh essen! Geh saufen!
Heute ist Ahnenforschung das
grosse Hobby des Wissenschaftlers.
Noch einmal erklärt er Sandra,
was man aus ihrer DNA
alles herauslesen kann.
(Mit amerikanischem Akzent)
Also man sieht zuerst,
was zu 100 % europäisch ist.
- Ja.
Französisch und deutsch - 35 %.
Und aus Grossbritannien 31 %.
Die meisten Leute sehen das
und sagen, das sei gut,
sie hätten etwas Gutes
für 100 Fr. erhalten.
Und, aber ...
Es gibt noch etwas Wichtiges.
Man sieht auch DNA-Treffer.
D.h. Cousinen, deren DNA
mit meiner übereinstimmen.
Für Gregory war sofort klar:
Sandras vermuteter Samenspender
ist es nicht.
Ich habe seine Eltern gefunden
und seine Vorfahren.
Grossvater, Urgrossvater usw.
Und alles war jüdisch.
Und das stimmt nicht
mit der DNA von Sandra überein.
Also, wir müssen von vorne beginnen.
- Ja, genau.
Es war für mich
eine grosse Enttäuschung.
Auf einmal ist mir eingefallen,
dass ich noch Namen habe.
Ein Stück Papier.
-Ich hatte noch diese Zettel.
Ich habe ihm dann
diese Namen genannt.
Ich habe mit Nummer 2, 3, 4
angefangen.
Was hast du
bei Nummer 2 herausgefunden?
Osteuropa oder Italien.
Ja, das passte einfach auch nicht.
Und bei Nummer 3 habe ich gesagt ...
Du hast gesagt,
wir würden morgen weitermachen.
Du hast mir den Namen gegeben
und gesagt, du müsstest schlafen.
Ich habe weitergearbeitet.
Dann habe ich
sehr schnell seine Eltern
und seine Vorfahren gefunden.
Und ein ... Er ist gestorben.
Er ist 2016 gestorben, oder?
- Ja.
Ich habe sehr schnell seine Vorfah-
ren und einen Lebenslauf gefunden:
"Alles stimmte. Alles stimmte."
"Uh! Ich gebe es ihr,
aber sie schläft."
"Doch, ich gebe es ihr."
Und, bald erhielt ich ...
Sie schrieb:
"Er ist es! Er ist es!"
Anhand des Fotos und des Lebenslaufs
wusste ich eigentlich schon,
dass das mein Vater ist.
Ich habe das Foto gesehen ...
Und die Augen - ich wusste: "Er ist
mein Vater. Er ist es. Er ist es."
"Ich bin angekommen."
Aus diesem Lebenslauf
haben wir erfahren,
dass ich von dieser Familie
noch drei Halbbrüder habe. - Ja.
Das sind aber keine Spenderkinder,
sondern richtige Kinder
einer richtigen Familie.
Während Sandra ihre Herkunft
endlich einwandfrei klären kann,
wird Roli in einem
amerikanischen Supermarkt fündig.
* Hupen *
Das passt gut zu ihrer Geschichte,
dass sie ihre Wurzeln nie vergisst.
Gregory hat von Sandras neuer Familie
einen Stammbaum erstellt.
War das nach all dem Suchen
nicht eine riesige Enttäuschung,
dass der Vater bereits gestorben ist?
Nein.
Im ersten Moment, als ich das Foto
und den Lebenslauf gesehen habe,
war damals die Enttäuschung
wirklich sehr klein.
Ich war so froh,
dass ich ihn endlich,
endlich gefunden hatte
und dass ich nun mehr über
meine Herkunft erfahren konnte.
So nahe ist Sandra
also ihrem Ziel gekommen
und hat zum Glück noch Halbbrüder,
die mehr
über den verstorbenen Vater wissen.
Die zeigen allerdings zunächst
wenig Interesse daran,
plötzlich eine Halbschwester
zu bekommen.
Genau genommen ist Sandra
nach Amerika gereist, ohne zu wissen,
ob ihre Brüder überhaupt bereit sind,
sie zu treffen.
Aber dann die Überraschung:
Der jüngste Halbbruder
ist endlich einverstanden damit,
sie kennenzulernen.
Wir haben kommuniziert und es
war nicht sicher, ob wir uns sehen.
Jetzt hat er geschrieben, er habe
Zeit, und wir treffen ihn jetzt.
Wir müssen jetzt 6 1/2 Std. mit
dem Auto fahren, aber das ist egal.
* Sanfte Musik *
Bye, bye!
- Thank you very much.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Und nun geht es erneut quer
durch Kalifornien nach Greenville,
200 km östlich von San Francisco,
um Dans jüngsten Sohn zu besuchen.
Allerdings möchte er unter keinen
Umständen eine Kamera dabeihaben
und Sandra respektiert den ausdrück-
lichen Wunsch aller drei Söhne,
dass weder Namen noch Bilder
ihres Vaters veröffentlicht werden.
Allein die Begegnung mit einer
völlig unbekannten Halbschwester
wird aufwühlend genug werden.
* Sanfte Musik *
Greenville, ein kleines Städtchen
in der Sierra Nevada.
In diese einsame und wilde Gegend
zog Sandras Vater
nach seinem Medizinstudium,
um an verschiedenen Orten
als Arzt zu praktizieren.
Zuletzt viele Jahre in dieser
ehemaligen Goldgräbersiedlung,
inmitten von Ureinwohnerland.
Und direkt an der berühmten
Central Pacific Eisenbahnlinie,
die bis zur
amerikanischen Westküste geht.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Die Heimat ihres Vaters und die erste
Begegnung mit ihrem Halbbruder -
hat Sandra jetzt
ihre Wurzeln gefunden?
Wir sind
sehr herzlich empfangen worden.
Es war sehr emotional.
Es war eigentlich
ein sehr natürlicher Umgang.
Wir haben sehr viel geredet
und auch sehr viel geweint.
Es ist auch noch nicht lange her,
seit mein Vater gestorben ist.
Es ist für ihn auch schwierig
und es muss viel verarbeitet werden.
So gesehen ist es aber ein Ankommen?
Ja, sehr. Sehr.
Total, ja.
* Vereinzelte Klavierklänge *
Sandra kommt noch einmal
zur ehemaligen Wirkungsstätte
ihres Vaters zurück.
Das war diese Klinik.
Hier hat mein Vater gearbeitet.
In der ganzen Region hat es
anscheinend nur zwei Ärzte gegeben -
und er ist einer davon gewesen.
Man hat Geld gesammelt,
um die Klinik
am Leben erhalten zu können.
Irgendwann hatte es einfach
nicht mehr genügend Leute
und es lohnte sich nicht mehr,
die Klinik weiterzuführen.
Wir sind
mit meinem Halbbruder hergekommen
und er hat mir wirklich alles
sehr genau erklärt.
Zufällig waren die Türen geöffnet
und wir konnten in die Klinik.
Sie war 20 Jahre
lang nicht geöffnet,
aber genau an dem Tag war sie offen.
Türen gehen auf. Die Brüder wollen
auch mal in die Schweiz kommen.
Eine neue Familienbande entsteht,
auch wenn der gemeinsame Vater
nicht mehr dabei sein kann.
Es ist unglaublich.
Ich habe 14 Jahre intensiv gesucht
und jetzt bin ich
auf einmal am Ziel.
Ich weiss jetzt alles über ihn.
Alles, was man wissen kann.
Es ist ...
Es ist ein megagrosses Geschenk,
dass ich das erleben darf.
Ich bin einfach auch sehr dankbar.
Allen gegenüber.
Niemand hat einen Fehler gemacht.
* Sanfte, emotionale Musik *